the unmistakable were of a Formula e car
is one of the most distinctive sounds in
sports it is far from the usual war on a
racetrack but what formula e lacks in
volume it makes up for in intensity and
everything else we build and are very
coordinated way so he's like a huge kind
of ballet the man in charge of formula E
is Alejandro a God is there an
instruction manual here there is yeah we
first met him in England in 2014 months
well here we are five years later yeah
we're still alive we're still here I
mean think about that what I didn't even
know that cars were gonna work I
remember when you were there with us at
the first ever test only 10 cars on the
grid when I kind of test that to see if
the theme was gonna was gonna even move
and here we are five years later in New
York and he's probably the fastest
growing motorsport in the world many
people thought should have failed yeah
everyone thought we were gonna fail I
think only I thought maybe when attends
formula e races are short only about 45
minutes and take place on tight tracks
in city center's speeds can hit a
hundred and seventy-five miles an hour
contrast that to Formula one the most
popular racing league in the world these
classic combustion engines race on wider
far longer courses and are still far
more powerful
but Jean Eric Vern who once drove
Formula One and is now Formula Eze top
rated driver says it's not so simple
frankly more scared in qualifying lap in
family than I wasn't Formula One yeah
because you know the TriCaster narrow it
is a heavy car very difficult to break
the handling is is not as good as an f1
so therefore it makes the driving a lot
more difficult and mistakes happen a lot
quicker Andre Lotterer
is Verne's teammate he showed us inside
a formula e vehicle the battery takes
the engine space so the battery is
inside this safety shell it's pretty
impressive each costs about a million
dollars and weighs 1,500 pounds more
than half that is battery weight you
have to look at form ie like almost like
we're at the beginning of a new chapter
in automobile industry in racing in
previous seasons drivers had switch cars
because batteries couldn't last the
whole race this year that is no longer
the case battery power has improved
dramatically the logistics of moving
those batteries and everything else from
city to city is mind-boggling in
Brooklyn nearly 700 people have been
working nonstop this week to build a
track from scratch
the cars were unpacked on Wednesday
testing was Friday racing on Saturday
and Sunday the whole event will cost
formula e between 10 and 15 million
dollars a week we'd be learning and in
four days we mount everything so it's a
huge operation but is it all worth it a
god says investing in the future and
losing money for now is as his league
aims to become not just the number one
electric race series but the number one
race series period
it's tricky though because both formula
1 and formula E are regulated by this
same organization an older brother and
younger sibling battling for attention
there's no other way to say it I mean
it's a contentious relationship is it
gotten any better do you think I feel I
mean I don't have any problem with
formula 1 um I love from no one I think
it's great but obviously as the industry
shifts towards electric formula one
finds more and more itself without an
industry to relate to so formula 1 goes
away I don't know how long does all this
take are we talking about 5 years from
now 20 years from now I think we're
talking 10 years from now this was seen
by a lot of people when it started as a
novelty right right is it still a
novelty it's not still novelty to
manufacturers Travis a Kolski image is
the editor-in-chief of road and track I
mean it's interesting to think about
because they've been around for 5 years
but it's still in its infancy right
we've got to think about formula 1 has
been on since 1950 right we've got 7
almost 70 years of history with this one
sport to develop become the pinnacle of
motorsport formula e comes in with new
technology and it's their first time
trying to make an impression it's going
to take time to become the pinnacle of
Motorsports if it does right that's a
big if formula e has developed gimmicks
that purists scoff at and Santa uses his
fan base a fan boost which lets users on
social media give their favorites more
juice this year attack mode which lets
drivers get more power by steering
through a special zone
not unlike in the videogame Mario Kart
we have to move even more towards the
videogame we're not halfway there yet
so the future is electric and it's
videogames the future is electric and
it's a combination between real life and
videogames combination between real and
virtual that's the future for an
American audience watching this weekend
what do you think they'll take away we
try to go to the American public and
show them electric cars I think if you
see this race you're one step closer to
buy an electric car that's why we do it
and that's why people come in here and
we get more and more people coming again
and again here in Brooklyn they will
feel closer to buy an electric car
that's our objective